now relive some iconic vegas nostalgia
too
that's right well circus circus is
welcoming families and thrill-seekers
back to the adventure dome
and rocky theis is giving us a sneak
peek of all the safe fun
you can have we are inside the adventure
dome and like every other business
around
the world you've got to make your
pandemic pivot so what changes have you
made song
so we've put social distancing every on
all the rides
you don't have to ride with a stranger
you ride with the people that you came
with
and just having fun here for spring
break
everybody's tired of being in the house
and they're out having fun
yes and of course i'm seeing everybody
with their mask on
you're encouraging people to just come
with their small family or small group
right stay in their small group
okay okay so when they do get here oh my
gosh
i'm not even on the roller coaster
i'm not even on it imagine me on it okay
i'm such a whip when it comes to rise
nowadays but let's take a walk i want to
show everybody
around the adventure dome um now
you've been doing this a long time and i
hear your offices
are inside this dome it's inside the
mountain
it shakes every time the coasters go
around what i get i get used to
it but other people that aren't used to
it they start grabbing for the walls
real fast so they're like me
so they're like me so i understand that
there's a there's a dream team
here at the adventure dome and you're
part of it and as the vice president
of attractions here you actually come up
with the designs for all the roller
coasters and rides
we have the owner and the president of
the property and the senior vice
president operations the engineering of
course because they have to maintain it
and then we've got to pick things that
are fun that adds to the mix
and which also fits inside the dome here
too so
every ride we put in it's like building
a ship and a bottle oh my god that's
some serious engineering that you guys
are doing
and of course i understand it's it's a
dome it's a cave vibe right
so the style is really fun as well it's
it's a lot of fun
there's a lot of things going on here
that we have 25 rides and attractions
and we're planning on having two to
three more additions and that's really
exciting
we're still coming up with uh what's
actually going to be the best fit for
the
ride mix in here so there's something
for everybody that is very something
something that has been here for so many
years but still evolving still changing
still getting better clean safe fun
that's
that's our motto and we want to continue
to add to the excitement
put in a new ride so people come back
and enjoy the park
i love it so tell everybody what your
new spring break hours are
spring break we're open 10 to midnight
and uh we're excited to have everybody
out
and having fun with their family and
friends okay so if there was one ride
you can get me on
which one would it be i would recommend
the roller coasters are the most popular
but we have something for everybody
carousels
ferris wheels bumper cars so it just
depends on what you're courageous enough
to do
i think bumper cars is is uh just right
for me
you can do bumper cars that's much level
i can handle but thank you so much time
this place is so cool
i'll send it back to you